Sharon Bell regularly walks mask beach
in t-side one day in October 2021 was
like nothing she'd ever seen there was
literally thousands and
I couldn't estimate the figure to be
honest
we were walking on them
a different investigation concluded the
thousands of dead and dying crabs and
lobsters was most likely caused by a
bloom of toxic algae but Sharon says
marine life is still dying far from over
you were what were you more than a year
on now and it was literally only two
weeks ago when I was filming hundreds of
muscles right along here it hasn't gone
away
logs obtained from local Fisheries
officials show nearly 50 wash-ups of
dead marine life from Seals and seabirds
to shellfish in the 12 months since the
mass die off ended in December 2021
marine biologist Gary Caldwell thinks he
has an explanation his research
commissioned by local fishermen and
campaigners identified an industrial
toxin called pyridine as the most likely
cause and when we actually did that work
and we got our heads around the toxicity
that was effectively the final bit of
the jigsaw puzzle for us because it was
incredibly toxic more so than you would
expect
two crabs and lobsters
fishermen are convinced that a major
dredging operation on the teas in 2021
caused the initial die-off defra
commissioned an independent expert
review of The Evidence which will report
later this month
while we wait for answers big dredging
projects are continuing in the tease
estuary
this vessel behind me has a permit to
remove 145
000 tons of potentially contaminated
sediment and dump it three miles out to
sea
this dredging work and that for the
government-backed t-side Freeport nearby
is crucial for the local economy so
fishermen calling for it to stop till
the facts are known is contentious
none of us nobody in the Northeast
fishing Collective is against the
Freeport of course we want jobs around
here but it shouldn't have been a free
part at the sacrifice of the fishing
industry of the ecosystem
what's going on later then defra says
the die-offs of marine life since
December 21 Are Not Unusual and that
it's ruled out contaminated sediment as
a Cause
but that puts them at odds with many
people who feel they know this Coast
well Tom Clark Sky News t-side